un tir au but qui marquera l'histoire de
montigny le bretonneux ce dimanche 16
septembre 3ème tour de la coupe de
france les hymnes 1 qui évolue en d2 de
district ont réussi à éliminer
choisy-le-roi une équipe qui évolue
pourtant trois divisions au dessus score
final 0 à 0 à 5 tirs au but à 3 on est
hyper content je mangeais pas trop les
mots parce que sa première fois je me
suis fait cette façon là et a du coup à
très heureux très heureux on a été
solidaires et ça le foot
la satisfaction de cette rencontre du
côté ini montain restera la défense
ont-ils le bretonneux qui avait encaissé
quatre buts lors de la première journée
du championnat de d2 contre guyancourt a
cette fois ci réussi à résister face à
l'armada offensive de choisy le roi
très clairement on était en étant en
dessous physiquement techniquement on
était en dessous mais on a été très
solidaire tactiquement les joueurs ont
fait preuve de rigueur donc voilà c'est
très positif
ils ont fait un match de coupe de france
s'attendent à voir de france costaud
dans les duels
c'est 0-0 il
montigny le bretonneux jouera son
quatrième tour de la coupe de france le
30 septembre prochain l'adversaire lui
n'est pas encore connue n'importe quelle
équipe on vous continuez n'importe
laquelle franchement ya pas deux fois en
une on continue une épopée écrit un
autre histoire à nous faire quelque
chose monti le bretonneux rêve déjà de
remplir le stade de la coupe pour ce
rendez vous et les supporters ne
demandent qu à l'enflammer